Ласкаво просимо до сирного раю!
Тут народжується чарівна сирна посипка, яка будь-яку страву може зробити кращою.
Ну справді - назвіть бодай одну страву, яку б не довершив сир.
Макарони із сиром, піцца, сирне фондю… І просто скибки на хлібі.
Я їв багато сиру, коли почав відмовлятися від м'яса. Однак…
Щоб зробити сир, потрібне молоко. А щоб виготовити це молоко, необхідні тварини,
які продукують величезну кількість парникових газів, а також споживають багато води.
Ну тобто - я люблю сир, але нам слід про це поговорити.
Наскільки цей витвір кулінарного мистецтва завдає шкоди довкіллю?
Чи слід відмовлятися від нього? І чи є кращі альтернативи?
Найкращий спосіб розібратися в цьому - зробити сир самотужки!
Сировари Пауль і Юле зголосилися показати мені, як проходить їхній робочий день.
Насамперед ми маємо заїхати за молоком на ферму у передмісті Берліна.
Пауль працював раніше на великі молочні компанії, але залишив їх, аби виготовляти власний сир.
Ось і молоко! Нам потрібно лише кілька хвилин, щоб набрати приблизно 250 літрів.
Скільки літрів вам потрібно, щоб зробити кілограм сиру?
Це залежить від рецепту сиру та від складу молока.
Нам дуже пощастило, що ми працюємо з молоком корів джерсейської породи.
Ці корови дають молоко з дуже високим вмістом мінералів та вітамінів.
Тому ми отримуємо кращі і більші надої, ніж якби ми, наприклад, брали молоко корів голштинської породи.
Але загальне правило: для таких сирів, як чеддер чи гауда, пропорція становить 10 до одного.
Тобто на один кілограм сиру вам потрібно десь 10 літрів молока.
Кількість молока надважлива, тому що, згідно з різними дослідженнями,
від 80 до 95 відсотків викидів парникових газів при виробництві сиру припадає саме на молоко.
Отже, чим більше молока використовують під час виготовлення сиру, тим гірше це для планети.
Більше половини цих викидів відбувається в результаті сільськогосподарських процесів.
Корови та інші тварини, які дають молоко, вироблять метан у ході життєдіяльних процесів.
Метан - це газ, який у 84 рази сильніше, ніж CO2, нагріває планету.
Але молоко різних тварин залишає різний вуглецевий слід.
Найменше його у  коров’ячому та буйволовому молоці - відповідно 2,8 кг та 3,4 кг СО2 на кілограм молока.
Негатив ний вплив козячого та овечого молока вдвічі більший - 5,2 кг і 8,4 кг діоксиду вуглецю відповідно.
Тобто у розрахунку на кілограм молока великі тварини забруднюють планету менше.
Це тому, що корови чи буйволи виробляють більше молока, ніж, наприклад, вівці чи кози.
І оскільки всі ці тварини жуйні і продукують метан,
вуглецевий слід сиру насправді навіть більший, ніж від курятини чи навіть свинини.
Більше викидів, ніж від м'яса - це ж божевілля!
У будь-якому разі, коли ми отримали молоко, ми повинні його нагріти і додати певні бактерії.
Наша мета сьогодні - перетворити це у смачненький ніжний сир. Кипить!
Цей сир особливо "щасливий", коли сировар відчуває, що в кімнаті трохи заспекотно.
Тому, якщо вам важкувато і здається, що ви в сауні, - сиру це подобається.
Гаразд, гаразд!
Тепер ми починаємо процес під назвою "ферментація".
Бактерія живиться від цукру, який є в молоці, розщеплюючи його.
Через деякий час додаємо рідину, яка називається сичужним ферментом.
Це те, що перетворює нашу суміш на сир, оскільки відновлює в ній казеїн -
білок, який можна знайти тільки в молоці тварин.
І так, це справді працює. Наше молоко раптово стало твердим.
Це дуже відрізняється від молока, яке я знаю. О так, тепер моя рука в ньому!
Я знову розрізаю його на шматочки.
І раптом усвідомлюєш, що 200 літрів молока можуть бути досить важкими.
Тепер треба працювати швидко.
Сир повинен потрапити в ці формочки, поки він ще теплий.
Через кілька хвилин ми його перевернемо.
Я і не думав, що зможу зробити це. Ось так просто.
Ось так.
А, добре.
Потім ти перевертаєш це.
Так, а потім кладеш назад.
Це коштує тобі 20 євро за кожну… краплю, яка падає на підлогу.
Відчуваю напругу!
Тобто фактично ти…
Вау, ідеально!
О, Боже!
Ще через дві-три години всі ці формочки прямують у камеру дозрівання - скарбницю сировара.
Є чимало різних сирів, які у порівнянні з цими, потребують витримки впродовж більш тривалого часу.
Від одного-двох місяців до навіть трьох років, як славнозвісний пармезан.
На безпосередньо виготовлення сиру припадає від 2 до 18% викидів CO2.
Але чим довше потрібно витримувати сир при певній температурі та вологості,
щоб він став смачнішим, тим більше енергії він споживає.
А тепер, нарешті, час смакувати!
Сирно! Дуже м'який на смак.
Неймовірно смачно!
Отож, для планети краще їсти моцарелу, а не пармезан.
І обирати опції з коров’ячим молоком замість сирів з овечого чи козячого молока.
Однак на ринку є й інші гравці, які здатні ще більше зменшити вуглецевий слід: веганські сири.
Хоча й вони можуть бути не такими екологічними, як ви думаєте.
Новий день, новий сировар. Однак сьогодні ми працюємо над веганською альтернативою.
У ній головними інгредієнтами будуть кеш'ю!
Це сировина, але як ми робимо з горіхів сир?
Це чудова особливість горіхів кеш'ю, ми можемо зробити з них смачне молоко.
Замочуємо їх, очищаємо і подрібнюємо.
Так утворюється ніжне молоко, з якого можна виробляти альтернативи сиру.
Аналогічно до того, як ми використовуємо тваринне молоко для традиційного сиру.
Після того, як подрібнили всі ці кеш'ю, додаємо бактерії, щоб почати процес бродіння -
подібно до того, як ми робили сир із молока тварин.
Зараз ми використовуємо кеш'ю, але це не єдина альтернатива.
Існує різна сировина для альтернативних видів сиру:
кеш'ю, мигдаль, овес, соя... навіть оливкова олія.
І через таку кількість інгредієнтів та розмаїття рецептів,
досить важко підрахувати викиди парникових газів або використання водних чи земельних ресурсів
під час виробництва веганських сирів.
Веганські сири відносно нові. Тому поки що не так багато досліджень щодо їхнього впливу на довкілля.
Ось чому ми можемо лише порівнювати те, що потрібно для вирощування найпопулярнішої сировини:
кеш'ю, мигдалю та нового інгредієнта - вівса.
Нідерландський національний інститут охорони здоров'я та довкілля порівняв їхній вплив на навколишнє середовище.
Інші дослідження наводять інші дані, але для легшого порівняння я дотримуюся цього.
Одне лише вирощування інгредієнтів для рослинних сирів вимагає більше води,
ніж все виробництво звичайного сиру.
Але саме виготовлення сиру виділяє більше CO2, ніж веганські альтернативи.
Важливо також пам’ятати, що не потрібен кілограм кеш’ю, мигдалю чи вівса,
щоб виготовити один кілограм альтернативного сиру.
Тут ми використовуємо лише пів кіло кеш’ю, щоб зробити один кілограм альтернативного сиру.
І коли ви порівнюєте це з десятьма літрами молока, які необхідні для виробництва кілограма традиційного сиру,
стає очевидним, чому кількість викидів парникових газів набагато нижча при виробництві альтернативних сирів.
Щойно бактерія почала працювати під час ферментації, додаємо трави і спеції.
Таку версію в компанії називають "чакалака".
Щоб стати максимально смачною, ця маса проходить схожий процес дозрівання, як у традиційного сиру.
Бактерії тим часом продовжують працювати.
Щоб допомогти їм, сир слід час від часу перевертати.
Дерева кеш’ю у В’єтнамі переважно вирощують у сухих районах,
оскільки коріння йдуть дуже і дуже глибоко в ґрунт. Це також зміцнює ґрунт.
Але для вирощування кеш’ю теж потрібно багато води.
Згідно з нідерландським дослідженням, це аж 2000 літрів води на кілограм кеш’ю.
Але справа не тільки у цифрах. Вплив різниться від регіону, де вирощують кеш’ю.
Скільки там опадів? Чи це регіон з дефіцитом води?
Гаразд. Тепер мені справді цікаво, як цей сир смакуватиме.
О так. Їси і відчуваєш трави.
Консистенція досить схожа до крем-сиру, але з травами й іншими інгредієнтами, це справді чудово!
Гаразд, це смакує непогано навіть для любителя сиру,
але погоджуюся, що справжній сир все ж кращий на смак.
Та якщо розглядати це з екологічної точки зору, то в підсумку:
альтернативи сиру з тваринного молока завжди кращі.
Однак слід теж враховувати, які з цих альтернатив екологічніші.
Краще віддавати перевагу варіантам на основі вівса.
Однак вони тільки починають з’являтися на полицях супермаркетів.
Справжній сир завжди буде особисто для мене номером один,
однак я спробую переключитися і на інші смачні альтернативи.